des élections législatives qui seront
particulièrement scrutées la commission
électorale centrale promettent un
scrutin ouvert et transparent un système
de vidéosurveillance enregistrera
notamment plus de 70 heures d'image
moscou se dit attentif à toute ingérence
en tout en éclairant
les autorités se disent particulièrement
attentive aux jeux site tentatives de
manipulation de l'opinion dans le
contexte de cette élection ainsi un
rapport du parlement européen a retenu
l'attention de la diplomatie russe les
auteurs de ce rapport comme il l'appelle
or il me semble que ce n'est qu'une
sorte de compilation en sont arrivés à
dire que l'union européenne devrait être
prête à ne pas reconnaître les résultats
des élections à la douma et à soulever
la question de la suspension éventuelle
de la participation russe aux structures
parlementaires internationales en
particulier à l'assemblée parlementaire
du conseil de l'europe si les élections
se déroulent accompagné de violation des
principes démocratiques et des normes du
droit international comme auparavant
nous nous opposerons fermement à cette
ingérence inadmissible dans les
processus démocratiques nationaux de la
fédération de russie nous condamnons
fermement les tentatives systématiques
du corps des députés européens de
manipuler l'opinion publique européenne
et nous comprenons que ces tentatives
conduisent à un discrédit définitif du
parlement européen en tant qu organe
représentatif de l'union européenne
outre l'union européenne moscou a
également dans le viseur les géants
américains de l'internet il ya une
semaine l'ambassadeur américain en poste
à moscou était convoqué au ministère
russe des affaires étrangères
et durant cet entretien il lui a été
signifié que la russie disposer de
preuves irréfutables de violation de la
loi russe par les grands acteurs
américains du numérique comme on peut le
voir les autorités sont donc sur le
qui-vive concernant ce scrutin capital
dans un contexte international
particulièrement tendu